en tunisie les autorités se préparent
ten cinquième vague le var et omikron se
propage dans le pays malgré la mise en
place n'est pas ce vaccinale le 22
décembre dernier le comité scientifique
tunisiens souhaitent le retour du couvre
feu et l'application stricte du
protocole sanitaire le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassam chez lui
après un été meurtrier suivie d'une
période d'accalmie est la tunisie semble
se diriger tout droit vers une cinquième
vague selon elle est membre du comité
scientifique de lutte contre le
coronavirus plus de 200 mille nouveaux
cas pourraient être enregistrés dans les
deux semaines à venir alors que plus de
50 % de la population a complété son
schéma vaccinal et que le pass and iter
est en vigueur depuis presque un mois
les voyants sont au rouge avec une aux
inquiétant des contaminations le comité
scientifique a indiqué hier soir qu'il
allait proposer de nouvelles mesures au
gouvernement notamment la mise en place
d'un couvre-feu partir de 22 heures et
ce pour trois semaines le durcissement
du contrôle des passes tu à lithaire ou
encore l'interdiction des rassemblements
face à la propagation du variant omicron
dans le pays le gouvernement se veut
rassurant et espère freiner la
propagation du virus par une nouvelle
sensibilisation aux gestes barrières et
l'arrivée de nouveaux vaccins dans le
cadre de la troisième dose écouter
notre pays est bien préparé pour
affronter cette cinquième vague via
notamment l'accélération de la campagne
nationale de vaccination
les mesures déjà prises reste toutefois
insuffisante nous sommes persuadés que
les gestes barrières et la réception de
la troisième dose de vaccin sont des
facteurs primordiaux pour espérer
freiner la propagation de cette épidémie
et faire face aux risques de la nouvelle
vague qui se propage selon les derniers
chiffres du ministère de la santé la
tunisie avoisine les 750 mille cas
confirmés et a dépassé les vingt-cinq
mille décès depuis l'apparition de
l'épidémie près de 400 patients sont
toujours hospitalisés dont 106 en
réanimation et 16 sont respiration
artificielle